so
[Music]
welcome to alliance military database
classified information requested
establishing secure connection
secure connection confirmed
[Music]
please log in to access your profile
reconstruction complete
identification confirmed
[Music]
well what about shepard earthborn
but no record of his family
doesn't have one he was raised on the
streets learned to look out for himself
he saw his whole unit die on a cruise he
could have some serious emotional scars
every soldier has scars shepard's a
survivor
is that the kind of person we want
protecting the galaxy
that's the only kind of person who can
protect the galaxy
i'll make the call
[Music]
the arcturus prime relay is in range
initiating a transmission sequence
[Music]
we are connected
calculating transit mass and destination
[Music]
the relay is hot acquiring approach
vector
all stations secure for transit
[Music]
has begun
[Applause]
[Music]
getting the relay
thrusters check navigation
check internal emissions sync engaged
all systems online
drift
just under 1500k
1500 is good your captain will be
pleased
i hate that guy
nilas gave you a compliment
so you hate him
you remember to zip up your jumpsuit on
the way out of the bathroom that's good
i just jumped us halfway across the
galaxy and hit a target the size of a
pinhead so that's incredible besides
spectres are trouble i don't like having
them on board
call me paranoid you're paranoid the
council helped fund this project they
have a right to send someone to keep an
eye on their investment
yeah that is the official story
but only an idiot believes the official
story
you always expect the worst
well bad feelings are an occupational
hazard
we don't go anywhere unless there's a
good reason so
what are we doing here joker
status report
just cleared the mass relay captain
stealth system is engaged
everything looks solid good
find a calm buoy and link us into the
network
i want mission report relayed back to
alliance brass before we reach eden
prime
aye aye captain
better brace yourself sir i think
nihilus is headed your way he's already
here lieutenant
tell commander shepard to meet me in the
calm room for a debriefing
you get that commander
i'm on my way
is it me or does the captain always
sound a little pissed off only when he's
talking to you joker
[Music]
congratulations commander looks like we
had a smooth run you heading down to see
the captain
sounds like you don't trust our turian
guest
sorry commander just having a chat with
adams down at engineering i didn't mean
to cause any trouble
but you have to admit something's odd
about this mission the whole crew feels
it
you think the alliance brass is holding
out on us
if all we're supposed to do is test out
the stealth system why is captain
anderson in charge and then there's
niles
specters are elite operatives top covert
agents
why send a spectre a turry inspector on
a shakedown run
it doesn't add up
do you have a problem with the captain
no sir
but i can't figure out what he's doing
here captain anderson is one of the most
decorated special forces officers in the
service if he melted down all his medals
he could make a life-size statue of
himself
you don't send a soldier like that on a
do-nothing mission
he's treating the shakedown run too
seriously
something big is going on i'll see if i
can get some answers when i see him
good luck
[Music]
i commander up on eden prime dock it's
not the kind of place vectors visit
there's something
what do you think commander we won't be
staying on eden prime too long will we
i'm itching for some real action i
sincerely hope you're kidding corporal
your real action usually ends with me
patching up crew members in the
infirmary
only a fool goes looking for a fight
corporal
sorry commander but this waiting's
killing me i've never been on a mission
like this before not one with a specter
on board
just treat this like every other
assignment you've had and everything
will work out
easy for you to say you proved yourself
on a cruise everybody knows what you can
do this is my big chance i need to show
the brass what i can do
you're young corporal you have a long
career ahead of you don't do something
stupid to mess it up
don't worry sir i'm not gonna screw this
up
the captain's waiting for me goodbye
commander
commander shepard i was hoping you'd get
here first people give us a chance to
talk
the captain said he'd meet me here he's
on his way
i'm interested in this world we're going
to eden prime
i've heard it's quite beautiful
they say it's a paradise yes a paradise
serene tranquil safe
eden prime has become something of a
symbol for your people hasn't it proof
that humanity can not only establish
colonies across the galaxy but also
protect them
but how safe is it really
if you've got something to say just say
it your people are still newcomers
shepard the galaxy can be a very
dangerous place
is the alliance truly ready for this
i think it's about time we told the
commander what's really going on this
mission is far more than a simple
shakedown run
is someone gonna fill me in captain
we're making a covert pickup on eden
prime
that's why we needed the stealth systems
operational
there must be a reason you didn't tell
me about this sir this comes down from
the top commander
information strictly on a need to know
basis
a research team on eden prime
unearthed some kind of beacon during an
excavation
it was prothean
i thought the protheans vanished 50 000
years ago their legacy still remains
the mass relays the citadel our ship
drives it's all based on prothean
technology this is big shepherd
the last time humanity made a discovery
like this it jumped our technology
forward 200 years but eden prime doesn't
have the facilities to handle something
like this
we need to bring the beacon back to the
citadel for proper study
obviously this goes beyond mere human
interests commander this discovery could
affect every species in council space
it never hurts to have a few extra hands
on board the beacon's not the only
reason i'm here shepard nilus wants to
see you in action commander
he's here to evaluate you
what's going on captain
the alliance has been pushing for this
for a long time
humanity wants a larger role in shaping
interstellar policy
we want more say with a citadel council
the specters represent the council's
power and authority if they accept a
human into their ranks it shows how far
the alliance has come
not many could have survived what you
went through on a cruise
you showed a remarkable will to live a
particularly useful talent that's why i
put your name forward as a candidate for
the spectres
just tell me what i have to do i need to
see your skills for myself commander
eden prime will be the first of several
missions together
you'll be in charge of the ground team
secure the beacon and get it onto the
ship asap
niles will accompany you to observe the
mission
just give the word captain we should be
getting close to eden captain we got a
problem
what's wrong joker transmission from
eden prime sir you better see
this bring it up on screen
get down
we are under attack taking heavy
casualties and repeat heavy casualties
they came out of nowhere we need
everything cuts out after that no calm
traffic at all
just goes dead
there's nothing reverse and hold it 38.5
status report
17 minutes out captain no other alliance
ships in the area
take us in joker fast and quiet this
mission just got a lot more complicated
a small strike team can move quickly
without drawing attention
it's our best chance to secure the
beacon
grab your gear and meet us in the cargo
hold
telelenko and jenkins to suit up
commander you're going in
engaging stealth systems
somebody was doing some serious digging
here captain
your team's the muscle in this operation
commander go in heavy and head straight
for the dig site
what about survivors captain
helping survivors is a secondary
objective the beacon's your top priority
approaching drop point one
niles you're coming with us
i move faster on my own
niles will scout out ahead he'll feed
you status reports throughout the
mission otherwise i want radio silence
i don't like putting my life in the
hands of a turian sir niles is on our
side he wants you in this victim and he
wants that beacon
we've got his back captain the mission's
yours now shepard good luck
we are approaching from point two
ship perimeter secure commander
like smoke and death
this place got hit hard commander
hostel's everywhere
keep your guard up
what the hell are those
gas bags
oh god
what happened here
[Music]
so
rip right through his shields
we'll see that he receives a proper
service once the mission is complete but
i need you to stay focused
aye sir
so
i've got some burned-out buildings here
shepard
a lot of bodies
i'm gonna check it out
i'll try to catch up with you at the dig
site
[Music]
so
thanks for your help commander
gonna reach ashley williams of the 212.
you the one in charge here sir are you
wounded williams
a few scrapes and burns nothing serious
the others weren't so lucky
oh man
we were patrolling the perimeter when
the attack hit
we tried to get off a distress call but
they cut off our communications i've
been fighting for my life ever since
where's the rest of your squad we tried
to double back to the beacon but we
walked into an ambush
i don't think any of the others
i think i'm the only one left
any idea what kind of enemy we're facing
i think they're death
the geth haven't been seen outside the
veil in nearly 200 years why are they
here now
they must have come for the beacon
the dig site is close just over that
rise it might still be there
we could use your help williams aye aye
sir it's time for payback
move out
she
the beacons at the far end of this
trench
so
good
this is the dig site the beacon was
right here it must have been moved by
who our side of the gas hard to say
maybe we'll know more after we check out
the research camp you think anyone got
out of here alive
if they were lucky
maybe hiding up in the camp it's just on
the top of this ridge up the ramps
of plans shepard there's a small space
board up ahead
i want to check it out i'll wait for you
there
[Music]
looks like they hit the camp hard
it's a good place for an ambush keep
your guard up
oh god they're still alive
what did the guest do to them
[Music]
thank you
that door is closed security locks
engaged
[Music]
so
we thought this world was safe until the
death showed
[Music]
saren
lylas
this isn't your mission saren what are
you doing here
the council thought you could use some
help on this one
i wasn't expecting to find the gath here
the situation's bad
don't worry
i've got it under control
what is that off in the distance
[Music]
commander it's nyla
a turian
you know him
he's a specter he was with us
something's moving over behind those
crates
wait don't don't shoot i'm one of you
i'm human
what are you doing sneaking around back
there
i am sorry i was hiding from those
creatures
my name is powell i saw what happened to
that turian the other one shot him
i need to know how nihilus died
the other one got here first
he was waiting when your friend showed
up
he called him saren i i think they knew
each other
your friend seemed to relax
he let his guard down
and saren killed him
shot him right in the back
i'm just lucky he didn't see me behind
the crates
we were told the prothean beacon was
brought to the spaceport what happened
to it
it's over on the other platform probably
where that guy's sarin was headed he
hopped on the cargo train right after he
killed your friend
i knew that beacon was in trouble
everything's gone to hell since we found
it first that damn mothership showed up
let me attack
they killed everyone
everyone if i hadn't been behind the
crates i'd be dead
too we need to find that beacon before
it's too late
take the cargo train that's where the
other turian went
i i i can't stay here i need to get away
from all this
set the charges destroy the entire
colony leave no evidence that we were
here
[Music]
demolition charges the guest must have
planted them
hurry we need to find them all and shut
them down
so
[Music]
demolition charges the geth must have
planted them
hurry we need to find them all and shut
them down
[Music]
deploy
so
good
normandy the beacon is amazing
immediately actual working prothean
technology unbelievable it wasn't doing
anything like that when they dug it up
something must have activated it
roger normandy standing by
no don't touch it
we identified the ship that touched down
on eden prime
the normandy
a human alliance vessel it was under the
command of captain anderson they managed
to save the colony and the beacon
one of the humans may have used it
this human
must be
eliminated
doctor dr chocos i think he's waking up
you had us worried there shepard
how are you feeling
how did i end up here
how long was i out
about 15 hours
something happened down there with the
beacon i think
it's my fault i must have triggered some
kind of security field when i approached
it you had to push me out of the way
you had no way to know what would happen
actually we don't even know if that's
what set it off
unfortunately we'll never get the chance
to find out
the beacon exploded a system overload
maybe the blast knocked you cold the
lieutenant and i carried you back here
to the ship
i appreciate it
physically you're fine
but i detected some unusual brain
activity abnormal beta waves
i also noticed an increase in your rapid
eye movement science typically
associated with intense streaming
i saw
i'm not sure what i saw death
destruction
nothing's really clear
hmm i better add this to my report it
may
oh
captain anderson
how's our exo holding up doctor well all
the readings look normal i'd say the
command is going to be fine
glad to hear it
shepard i need to speak with you
in private
aye captain i'll be in the mess if you
need me
sounds like that beacon hit you pretty
hard commander
are you sure you're okay
chief williams isn't part of the
normandy crew
i figured we could use a soldier like
her she's been reassigned to the
normandy
williams is a good soldier she deserves
it
lieutenant olanko agrees with you that's
why i added her to our crew
you said you needed to see me in private
captain
i won't lie to you shepard
things look bad
nilus is dead
the beacon was destroyed and gather
invading
the council's going to want answers
the geth would have wiped out the whole
colony if i hadn't stopped them
i'll stand behind you and your report
shepard you're a damned hero in my books
that's not why i'm here
it's saren
that other turian saren's a specter one
of the best a living legend
but if he's working with the gift
it means he's gone rogue
a rogue specter's trouble
saren's dangerous
and he hates humans
he didn't come to eden prime because he
hates humans
you're right
sarin has allied himself with the geth
i don't know how i don't know why
but it had something to do with that
beacon
you were there just before that beacon
self-destructed did you see anything
any clue that might tell us what sarin
was after
just before i lost consciousness i had
some kind of vision
a vision
a vision of what
i saw synthetics
geth maybe
slaughtering people
butchering them
we need to report this to the council
shepherd
what are we going to tell them i had a
bad dream
we don't know what information was
stored in that beacon
lost prothean technology blueprints for
some ancient weapon of mass destruction
whatever it was sarin took it
but i know saren
i know his reputation is politics
he believes humans are a blight on the
galaxy
this attack was an act of war
he has the secrets from the beacon
he has an army of death at his command
and he won't stop until he's wiped
humanity from the face of the galaxy
i'll find some way to take him down
it's not that easy
he's a specter
he can go anywhere do almost anything
that's why we need the council on our
side
we prove saren's gone rogue and the
council will revoke his specter status
i'll contact the ambassador and see if
he can get us an audience with the
council
he'll want to see us as soon as we reach
the citadel we should be getting close
head up to the bridge and tell joker to
bring us into dark
hey commander
so
good timing commander i was just about
to bring us into the citadel see that
taxpayer money at work
[Music]
[Applause]
look at the size of that ship the
ascension flagship of the citadel fleet
wow size isn't everything
why so touchy joker i'm just saying you
need firepower too
look at that monster its main gun could
rip through the barriers in any ship in
the alliance fleet good thing is on our
side then
citadel control this is ssv normandy
requesting permission to land stand by
for clearance normandy
clearance granted you may begin your
approach
transferring you to an alliance operator
roger alliance tower
normally this is alliance tower please
proceed to dark 422
[Music]
this is an outrage the council would
step in if the geth attacked a taurian
colony
the turians don't found colonies on the
borders of the terminus systems
ambassador humanity was well aware of
the risks when you went into the
traverse what about saren you can't just
ignore a rogue specter i demand action
you don't get to make demands of a
council ambassador citadel security is
investigating your charges against sarin
we will discuss the susec findings at
the hearing not before
captain anderson i see you brought half
your crew with you just the ground team
from eden prime
in case you had any questions i have the
mission reports i assume they're
accurate
they are
sounds like you convinced the council to
give us an audience
they were not happy about it seren's
their top agent they don't like him
being accused of treason
saren's a threat to every human colony
out there if they don't stop him i will
settle down commander you've already
done more than enough to jeopardize your
candidacy for the specters
the mission on eden prime was a chance
to prove you could get the job done
instead nihilus ended up dead and the
beacon was destroyed that's saren's
fault not his then we better hope the
c-sec investigation turns up evidence to
support our accusations
otherwise the council might use this as
an excuse to keep you out of the
specters
come with me captain i want to go over a
few things before the hearing
shepard you and the others can meet us
at the citadel tower top level i'll make
sure you have clearance to get in
and that's why i hate politicians
[Music]
you